- I've ordered a million
paint by numbers sets--
- That'sーI love coloring so much.
Like, I never thought I'd be the girl
with adult coloring books,
but my kids are coloring
so much, and I'm like,
"Okay, I'm done with
princesses, at this point.
"I've gotta color something else."
It's actually very therapeutic.
- Yeah, I love doing it.
I was really into it, at the beginning,
and then, I sort of got out of it,
and now, I think I'm gonna dive back in.
- Yeah. I mean, well,
there's only so much to do,
when you're stuck in your house.
- True.
- Can I seeーdo you have anything?
Can we see?
- I do.
- Oh, you do?
Oh, good.
- I brought it.
I brought it, in case you wanted to see my
beautiful work.
- What?
(Dakota laughs)
Okay, Dakota.
Mine aren't looking anything like that.
- Oh, and I even date it in the corner.
Yes, very professional.
- Oh my gosh.
I'm not even kidding you.
I was thinking, like, water.
Maybe I'm an idiot, and
still stuck in the '80s.
I was thinking, like, you
know, watercolor things.
- I've done that, too.
- Not like that.
This is actually by a
brand, called Pink Picasso,
and they're like the
fancy paint by number.
It's like actually a canvas and like--
- Next level watercolor.
- I know, I was gonna get,
I can't, obviously.
It's all, you know,
it's just about filling in the little--
- No, I can promise you,
if I did that, girl, it
would not come out like that.
I'm not, that's not my kind of creativity.
- I was impressed. I kinda liked it.